[Applause]
they know all about civilians being
attacked here this small village
community just south of the ukrainian
capital
has been torn apart by russian bombs
almost an entire street disappeared in
an instant
three children and three adults were
killed devastating their families and
the whole neighborhood
the explosions have left a deep burning
anger and a thirst for revenge amongst
the men of the village who've taken up
arms to defend their community and their
country
i feel only hate he tells us we'll never
ever forgive them for this
another says they have to close the
skies the rest of the world have to
become involved and close the airspace
above ukraine
and their friend says we'll keep on
shooting them every time they shoot us
we'll shoot back and we won't leave any
alive we're going to kill every single
invader
those who survive the explosions are
still sifting through what's left of
their lives to piece together precious
possessions or memories
oksana tells us how scared they all are
we can't sleep at night she says
whenever they hear sounds they think
it's another bombing and they run out of
the house
her husband says the war has completely
upended their lives and left them
terrified we've no idea what's going to
happen he says when it's going to happen
or where
they're still reeling from the shock of
it all and i think it follows a pattern
of an increasing number of civilians and
civilian targets or civilian locations
which appear to be
targeted or certainly not
um off the agenda of the the russian war
machine
civilians are in the crosshairs of this
war a brief respite in shelling and
firing an urban on the outskirts of the
capital meant those still trapped were
finally able to escape
remember none of these people can be
certain they won't be fired on again
and they know their neighbors who fled
earlier were attacked
ukraine's former president petro
poroshenko has been busy rallying
volunteer fighters and soldiers
he's among a growing list of people
demanding safe passage for civilians
we were with him as he boosted morale
and championed the bravery of the troops
their job protecting the critically
important southern route out of the
capital is crucial and he brought fresh
weapons and supplies to help
if this route is taken by the russian
military the capital will be encircled
if ukrainians could win on defiance and
courage they would win but they need
more than defiance and courage don't
they and at the moment the capital is
slowly first of all
first of all remove the word if we
definitely win
this is first message
we will win with
or without
western assistance
because you see how strong is ukrainian
but
it takes significantly more time and
will need significantly more lives
and blood
and this is just
the decision from our
partners in the west do you
ready to give us the weapons do you
ready to increase the sanction
do you ready to do all of this to
minimize ukrainian blood and ukrainian
lives please do that immediately
the former president took us to see
another residential area which had been
hit
ukraine's heading for many more civilian
deaths he's warning and there are few in
the country confident enough to say
otherwise right now
alex crawford sky news in vassal kiev
he's already killed by